hello my little scourges ever wash your
car it's time for another male blog can
I feel too exposed so I'm gonna shut my
video sorry I got some ancho on voice
it's not to have anything weird in the
background I'm gonna be embarrassed by
no everything's fine um okay guys so I
haven't made a mail vlog in a while aha
I am a terrible person put me in jail
male jail I kept looking at myself um so
bye okay um so I have a [ __ ] ton of mail
to go through holy crap you guys are
awesome and you said so much stuff in my
little p.o box when it opened it it was
like get this out of me like me after I
cole slaw because it hurts my stomach
okay so first and foremost let me start
off I'm going to go kind of quick
because there's so much and I want to
make sure that everyone gets a chance
just make sure that I've gotten their
stuff um okay so I got a bunch of
packages these are all notices for
packages and the package windows aren't
always the package window is always
closed because that woman is like 330
I'm out of here and she leaves mr.
snowman and so tomorrow gonna try and
get packages look at all these you guys
holy crap uh and so I'm gonna do a
separate video with the package on Rosa
but for now let's go through everything
that's here let's go through the old
stuff that came first oh my gosh okay i
am bringing out Oh freaking out okay oh
my gosh this looks like it is not for me
and said it's for David W drinks what
this went to the wrong few bucks so I
should be taking this back mother f v8
having the add on extra stuff to do God
David drinks okay uh Jana Allen ooh from
Minnesota to make it a tiny coke it's
perfect it's the perfect way to start
off a male blog team anthrax huh mom is
that you this is like a joke my mom
would say uh thank you very much for
this Jana that was adorable of Tyler me
Cham ooh from Richmond Richie well look
at this party party this envelopes got
its period I can't lay everything way
too many period jokes it's making me
seem not intelligent whoa have a happy
birthday and not to some threatening or
anything or I will fight you it's a
little ninja and it's very stereotypical
Asian style writing Chuck Chuck Chuck
Chuck Chuck oh man this is a great card
thank you so so much Tyler I will read
this later sorry I'm not be able to read
much of your stuff today because I'm
trying to get through Crocs is this from
that [ __ ] that loves to write Crocs on
my wall and you're not a [ __ ] I'm just
kidding oh just kidding Crocs this girl
loves Crocs you can't stop yourself or a
friend lip crops and I don't know what
it is and it's some insight you up
between them and shake me back to high
school one girl side inside jokes and I
wasn't on the inside of the outside it's
me again Kylie Crocs I knew it I knew it
beautiful handwriting thank you very
much i'll beat that I'll read the rest
of this later but here's a sentence keep
[ __ ] that chicken that's from that
video with that news anchor hey so great
okay Monica Neil from Detroit you're
alive that's fine because to try don't
be like pow pow each other all the time
so that's good for you keep going leave
more I'm ripping apart this envelope for
use that later huh it's a picture of oh
I love grace ding ding she's awesome
this is awesome thank you so much for
making this this is so sweet of you you
guys are the sweetest little peaches
because you take time on your day to
write letters and send me things and
that is just insane insane it feels like
what is this Mina hey knows like famous
but with an N or maybe in age from
irvine california it feels thick haha
thick because i had to fold it a bunch
of time so that it would fit
inappropriate oh so you don't me to
think that there's like a prize in here
i say hey kid open you nice time mr. so
and you work with a red pen that always
makes me feel a little nervous because
teachers correctly stakes a friend pens
and so i have like brain memory of that
whoa this is like acid trippy look at
that that's so cool and you put it the
design at the bottom I like that I like
that unlocked that's like what I used to
scribble on my notebooks because I
didn't take notes I did I was a nerd
whoa colors Mina Mina fado's yes oh
there's so much in here and i will read
this thank you so much for sending this
and you made little glasses oh okay i
need to stop reading it inside my head
because however learn nothing from
previous videos of course not Sarah and
Adam Collins oh are you married or no
you must be brother and sister or
something I don't know I don't know why
I some married first oh my gosh oh my
god oh my god is it a boy or a girl that
I know a nose no one knows that is
amazed oh this 20
yeah that's I could shouldn't want to
look at it as much as I want to holy
crap great it's grace what tell them
what you with my brother and I love your
videos you are brother and sister okay
sorry to insinuate that you were married
um I made a cross stitch for you my
brother made the pattern of the bottle
huh they made a cross stitch oh holy
look at that oh my god that's so cool
thank you so much oh I want to like wear
it on my body and my person that is so
cool and then you gave me this one this
is from your brother Adam any dro taco
thank you guys so much this is so cool
I'm in a cross stitch lion when I was in
school and it's somewhere in my dad's
house and it was not good hmm I am NOT a
domestic woman whoa new views are you
got pace this is from Corey doe ack whoa
your last name is weird to me jack
sounds like something you will call like
uh when they're dumb you're making dough
act right now sorry I mean oh and just
making fun stop being mean to these
people you don't know oh oh oh it's a
picture of you guys shooting who's this
weakling in the middle that can't do it
get your arms up girl she'll never do
yoga just get in super sweet dough acts
the dou X open this open right and open
screech paper hi grace want to tell you
that I love your videos every time wash
them it I always die laughing corrido I
oh it's your mom cousin and sister oh
you got your mom cousin and sister hooks
on your videos oh thank you so much
that's so sweet of you oh that is the
sweetest street to nth from Noel
Campbell Oh from o co e Florida what
that what is that place they'd ever
recording yet small panic attack to the
ever sensational always a special oh
that is so nice okay I'm opening this
time open
ruined Otis flowers I see flowers
already thank you was a thank you card
Oh for being one of the coolest people i
have yet to meet oh that's so sweet
alvita Zane no well 40 Orlando it's what
that said no it doesn't say we're
landing on here but thank you so much
Noel this is super super sweet and thank
you and thank you i'm running out of
other words to say except for thank you
grace w and Mom for this is from a grace
w from [ __ ] rapids that sounds like what
you should call your vagina uh why my
sense of humor has just totally
diminished to vagina jokes and period
jokes why yes i used tape before grace
Helbig made it cool haha look at his
stickers why not all those crazy
stickers holy crap a pig's uh no pun is
awesome punch open please love from oh
I'm reading the back of it I should oh
look cutie patooties in look in the new
nuke and it's mine oh so sweet oh my
goodness oh it's a colouring thing it's
colored and it's an bunnies that is so
nice ah this picture was colored by my
four and a half year old daughter Grace
Olivia oh thank you thank you so much
that's so sweet oh who has popcorn
because my heart just melted in a pile
of butter what is these words Jesse
amorous whoo lots of double letters in
your name fun from Springfield Oh what's
mo Missouri I think don't feel bad if
you destroy the envelope trying to open
it thank the [ __ ] lord because that's
what I'm gonna do what into Tibet
oh so cute as a cartoon but I'm totally
terrified of them in real life because
they're gross but they taste delicious
oh so cute you deserve lots of cake
Jessie oh thank you jesse this is
awesome and i'm already getting glitter
everywhere who needs glitter body splash
no you can't see that Thank You Jessie
what's next Christie creature from
Corpus Christi Texas what that sounds
like that's made up Christy from Corpus
Christi did your parents know what they
were doing your parents are silly oh my
gosh i see drawings already look at
those third the icons yeah okay my name
is Kristy recent discovery of it is due
to the fact that I became very ill and
have been stuck at home for three weeks
yes disease brought you here I will read
this later Thank You Christy I hope that
you're feeling better and that even in
your healthy state you want to watch the
videos maybe who knows here we got one
from mr. de me Aras de Morris francis
from miami florida and there's look
obese Oh stickers tickets it goes colors
colors colors go girl I'm ruining your
envelope I'm sorry but if you love
something let it go grace I know that my
handwriting is horrible sorry oh please
get over yourself it's great anyways I
love your blog especially the ones where
you cook all good i'm glad you like them
oh these are all sweet words oh it's
pronounced damaris sorry dawg Maris you
get it all back that's not anything new
ok I'm going to open this one feels like
it's got a giant condom in it hmm
interesting Sarah pencil from Salem
Massachusetts Sarah what did you put in
here it's not a giant condom it's sex
has consequences the opposite of a jack
condo
all right I want to wear this and I also
don't want to wear this but I wanted in
my room someone put it there and open
this up grace whoa whoa look at that
who's that guy chillin out over there
how's it going my name is Sarah pencil
pronounced well like the writing utensil
I said it right hooray you can tell ms
chusetts stay awesome Papa but i will
read this oh you're going new york in
december you want to see short the pit
please do i hope to see you there PS
sexist consequences good to know thank
you so much that's so nice that bracelet
will be used for something CWB from
synovial and georgia gonna be big whoa
stars you're a star CWB sounds so thick
and this also feels oh cuz bubblicious
and hair I haven't had bubblicious since
I was a little girl and there's a paper
something this is an animal with a thing
this is the thing and I'm unfolding it
which is the opposite of what you should
do to work on me thank you for this
thing it Twitter at Chelsea girl that's
a simple one that girl you want
bubblicious echo has some let's say
grace oh I wasn't thinking I'm wrote my
letter on the inside of the butterfly oh
this is a butterfly it's on the inside
of there I'm not sure how to unfold it
but I'm sure it'd be entertaining to
watch love you lots oh I want a piece of
this cotton candy bubblegum right now so
I ever tell you guys that when I was
younger I used to steal bubblicious
bubble gum from the grocery store like
three or four when I was like three or
four and then my brother caught me and I
felt so horrible I never did it again
ever ever ever so this has a lot of
weird feelings coming up for me right
now it's blue oh Jessica [ __ ] mmm can't
wait to go to the dentist
okay good god Murray climber come to
sauna Arizona wowie hmm go huh ouch why
not use it in my letter openers because
I'm not efficient oh this baby looks
like an adult baby looks like a man let
go mmm like a man what is this I love
your good news I wanted to make you a
bracelet whoa for marine Murray made me
a bracelet oh my gosh I'm afraid I don't
want to ruin this little manchild baby
bag open oh it's so pretty in this okay
you see that it's a little um margarita
glass with a giant lime sticking out of
it this is adorable Thank You Marie
that's so awesome thank you ok this time
Patricia contrary rose from Calexico
California there's a really good mexican
place in brooklyn called calexico is
there one out there and collects about i
don't know you tell me oh there's a
package in here is all sorts of stuff
for the picture of you guys should grace
faces yeah oh you're having a good time
oh and I guess you made would you make I
should write the letter to be informed
just a picture up some hope that's not I
don't what is for thoughts going at once
great condense them you're probably
thinking what it isn't Christmas yes
look at all these Christmas things two
pictures from the day my friends and I
made chocolate chip cookies but instead
of using milk we used Bailey's haha
genius
it was good good I'm glad I want you to
picture you guys are so good things holy
crap holy crap that looks amazing and
then you put something in here what is
in here we do flying squirrel and then
what is this is says sorry for the
packaging I didn't want it to get
damaged okay please don't break Oh what
is it Oh what is it Oh what is it it
probably says it in the letter if I read
the whole letter oh and I think oh
you've made huh no this is so much you
did a good job packaging it whoa this is
fun I'm like a cat i play with the
packaging rather than the gift oh it's
like it's in a neck brace crap knows the
packaging sorry it's a great ski just
focus on the things that strangers have
given you for a second oh I'm gonna hurt
I'm gonna break it ah no no don't break
oh why am I doing this so wrong ah there
we go yeah look at it I'm my parent win
oh and it's it's gonna hold it in my
phone is ringing oh my gosh reform to
string you okay um I heard that go I'll
be right back and i'm back sorry about
that sorry haha like such a big deal oh
yeah make me gay okay um okay since
there's so much these are the last
things I'm going to open in this video
and then I went to another video with
the other things that I picked up today
and we will deal with it cool let's keep
going this is from doesn't say but it
says royal me like a queen on it oh so
this is obviously from principal am
asking me to marry him be a male cuz he
is old-fashioned what oh my god
it is when Prince William it's a unicorn
how did he know grace read this first
oops and that's just my bad uh whoa
fancy this did come from England holy
crap hey grace my name is Zoe so you
call yourself prince will you please
clarify to the viewers that i am not the
regular letter sender Zoe oh she's not
the regular when I was sending me
postcards um on your male 5 while you
got a letter with a rock on it and you
didn't know what rock was so I bought
some from the north of England to send
you whoa thank you you'll be moving to
France let's a timber first so say you
some mail from oh my gosh Thank You Zoe
I have fun in all français [ __ ] admit
Pam grace e de fromage thank you for
this ah that's so cool although Prince
William next time ok this is from
Kathleen may llamas like the animal your
life seems like an animal from Mount
Vernon New York I know where that is yo
man handled that what do we got here oh
it's a picture of flowers by
pierre-auguste renoir Renoir that guy
you know him hello kitty this is from
hello it's Cathal's oh hey grace what's
up hello whenever I hear someone say
what's up in real life I'm reminded of
your videos are you saying what's up
[ __ ] oh and put it closes a pair of
handmade earrings huh oh my gosh and the
origami origami thinks rme our bookmarks
what oh my goodness oh my goodness oh my
goodness huh you made these earrings
look at these oh oh oh no you're my
biggest fan oh my god that's so awesome
what's in this I don't want to break it
don't break it don't break it don't
break it oh these are so cute and their
bookmarks you use them to mark your
books cool I am
get some books thank you so so much
that's so sweet of you Kathleen a llamas
thank you that is so nice okay this is
from kara and Ken Mason ah are you
married and it's got some Canada postage
on it oh it's from Canada oh my gosh
it's from Canada I bet it's from them
and Celine Dion explain Dion in here is
she in here oh no she did not she could
fit in yo she looks like she's about 2
feet big what is this letter dear down
the grace can i call you daily hahaha
just jokes I got it this might attempt
at humor um my name is Kara pronounce
care of 23 she's a fine art student and
she has her own little arts and crafts
business called mid kid and my DK ID
whoa you owe you and you send me some of
your jewelry whoa oh my gosh oh my gosh
and oh my god oh my god
ash custom jewelry photography paintings
and murals mid kid guys make it look at
this thing look at this pretty thing oh
and it's so pretty huh and it's a
necklace if think oh that's so pretty
nice got like the things in it and the
thing you're looking at the thing of it
and nothing oh so pretty my goodness oh
and then look at the box is so cute the
boxes Oh Nicholas and it's gonna what
you set me look at that and the thing oh
look at this thing where is it your
other thing look at this then a little
box with the thing on it mid kid oh so
cute like a charm I like this a lot
Kapow look at those roses oh I'm going
to wear these in my dears huh thank you
so much guys do you like this job I go
to mid kid because it's adorable and I
like it so much thank you so much for
sending me that that's so kind of you
and I assume this is you and your
boyfriend husband the cuties look I'm
rubbing your faces not a scratch and
sniff ok last one thank you so much mid
kid com go check it out guys this is
from Oh someone with lovely handwriting
I didn't say but it's it's got British
male and it went through customs oh it
went to go from where you have from the
UK so were the UK somewhere in the
Prince William did send something oh
please don't ruin what's inside here
Buddhist olimpica whoops I'm making a
mess and I'm making a mess if you made
it all the way to this part of the video
coo Jose remember those food huh a
puzzle they sent me a puzzle a puzzle of
what
okay okay thank you nothing else look at
this so tiny little envelope otra tiny
oh and I've just broke the entire thing
of it this says good day to your grace
glad you got my studio is the person in
the CD I was a big concern that those
male pixie so always steal your mail got
holder then closes a bit of a whimsy in
a shape of a child's jigsaw puzzle I had
quite a few hours of fun with it enjoy I
have not sent the picture in order to
add an element of adult challenge to it
while you [ __ ] thank you you mother
[ __ ] thank you thank you oh my gosh
it's so nice and I will do this puzzle I
mean get drunk right now and do this
puzzle thank you guys for watching this
map boggin thank you for sending me mail
I still have all this other meal that I
picked up um it's just this is just
empty bag but all this other mail then I
picked up then I'm gonna open a couple
days and then you make up that video so
words are bye thank you you are the
sweetest little come